joining me now for reaction is
lieutenant Brian McGregor with the
Kenner Louisiana Police Department he's
investigating the attempted kidnapping
incident involving an illegal alien with
a machete at that Walmart that we just
told you about and in Alabama
sandi best she's a sister of Amy Hawkins
who we just told you was allegedly
killed by an illegal immigrant Jose Luis
Alonso de Leon as she was cycling in
Baldwin County Alabama DA Robert will
ters who's prosecuting MS Hawkins
alleged killer let's start with you
mister will ters this this broke my
heart today to hear this story coming
out of Alabama I actually learned about
it because one of my radio listeners
called into my show and said a colleague
of his is the is the actual husband of
the victim in this case and that he was
distraught and devastated and I said
well I looked it up and said indeed this
happened tell us about this case and any
more details that you've discovered
Laura thank you for having us on tonight
and ask you and your listeners to please
pray for Amy Hawkins family as they go
through this tragic time it seemed that
on Sunday at about 12:20 5 p.m.
Amy Hawkins was riding her bicycle on
one of our roads on the Eastern Shore
near Fairhope and Daphne and she was
northbound and the defendant in the case
Jose Luis Alonso de Leon was heading
southbound he swerved around a car to
pass and struck miss Hawkins who was
riding a bicycle you can did not stop
continued on and was found a couple of
miles away several minutes later he was
highly intoxicated at that time when he
was arrested by law enforcement they
also found a stolen pistol in the
we then have learned that through
checking NCIC that he has at least seven
aliases and according to ice immigration
enforcement he was deported twice during
2014 it's a tragedy that should never
happen now this this should never have
happened
sandy this is your sister I cannot
imagine what you are going through at
this moment and and it sounds Hollow to
say that but I am praying for you and
your family and everything that you've
gone through and her two children her
husband her entire family you if this
thing could have been vetted and he
could have been prevented from coming
into this country whether through a
physical barrier or through you know
effective deportation I mean your sister
would be alive would it IIIi despite
words don't even convey I am furious
about these cases and I am saddened and
I mean as devastated as I could be
without having known your sister yes
ma'am she she was a beautiful sister she
was a great mother a great daughter it
is a tragedy knowing that this is an
illegal alien with seven aliases there
trying to track down his criminal
history now and I'm sure mr. will ters
you'll be doing that by other crimes he
could have committed a stolen gun in his
possession could have very well gone on
if he already hadn't committing violent
acts against other people and it was
your sister's death at his hands that
caused his ultimate apprehension and I
assume will be put away for a long
period of time further thoughts on the
fact that this government was unable to
keep him out of this country tragedy
Thank You sandy wait sandy yes it it is
a tragedy nothing's gonna replace my
sister and and I'm I don't have the
answers to that I I loved her
and yes I he should have been deported
and he somehow we have to figure out a
way that he wasn't able to come back in
that he wasn't able to drive a vehicle
that he wasn't able to drive drunk I I
don't have the answer to that right now
I know is that my family is hurting over
the whole situation let's talk to
lieutenant McGregor the reason I wanted
to bring these stories to the American
people's attention tonight lieutenant
McGregor is because these aren't just
names on a piece of paper these these
Americans are personally devastated by
this type of crime and we almost had
another situation unfold in Kenner in
Louisiana about six miles from New
Orleans on Friday and one of our
contributors here is from New Orleans he
brought this to my attention Raymond
Arroyo said got someone with the machete
and in a Walmart trying to trying to
kidnap a little two-year-old then it
goes on to try to kidnap someone else
another person who shouldn't have been
in this country this is madness
lieutenant yes lieutenant McGregor your
thoughts about this case now as it
stands how did he get into this country
he was deported twice at least we
understand that's still things that
we're looking into we know on Friday at
2:00 p.m. he entered into Walmart
through the garden center he approached
the deli section of the store he engaged
a female they had a two-year-old in a
grocery cart you know he threatened that
female he also threatened the life of a
child as well he also put his hand on
Assad to indicate that he had a sheath a
machete on Assad you know that female
asked for help he reached to grab that
child and like any mother would she
fought for her child and grabbed her
child from that cart
you know proceeded to get that child on
the other side of that deli counter they
had some Walmart employees as well as
citizens and everything else everybody
else that engaged the suspect he ran
back into the meat poultry section of
the store he drew that machete he swung
it at employees who created distance
which allowed him to get back up into
the deli section where another
unexpected mother who was coming through
with a infant strapped into the grocery
cart he tried to grab that child while
he was still armed with machete oh my
god like it like any other mother would
she fought for her child as well
employees that was there in addition to
our kena police also that was off-duty
and was working a police detail at the
location they engaged the suspect got
him down on the ground handcuffed him
and took him into custody
those Walmart employees and the off-duty
I'm the off-duty officer tackle them
ultimately by walking walking into a
Walmart with a with a machete and
lieutenant McGregor didn't you you also
worked on a case three years ago as I as
I seem to recall involving a I think it
was a hurt Herrmann Rivera who raped a
ten-year-old girl another illegal
immigrant was at you on that case
there's I've had many cases I mean we
just finished up a murder with a
dismemberment if you look on the news it
was just very easily reported that we
have a conviction for second-degree
murder in addition to obstruction of
justice the reference to the know a
murder to happen here in Kenner and
which a individuals body was cut up and
dismembered and thrown in st. John
parish well and Kenner is a very safe
community for the most part you have
incredible policing incredible retention
recruitment keeping the community safe
and in the community in Alabama we're
talking about they're also very safe
community but New Orleans itself is a
sanctuary City correct and you have
bleed through from New Orleans into your
your community Mitch Landrieu's worried
about you know tearing down statues in
the middle of the night that's his big
focus but meanwhile illegal immigrants
are able to you know make it it would
make their way into your community
I want to ask both of you law
enforcement how important is it for
local authorities to cooperate with the
federal government on this immigration
issue and to get these people imprisoned
and then out of the country we'll go
back to you mr. Wilton well it's very
important law and in the last year
there's been tremendous cooperation
between local law enforcement and
immigration authorities where for eight
years we didn't have it so having the
knowledge that we can contact ice and
that ice will actually come in in place
a detainer on a illegal immigrant helps
us tremendously there's still some more
kinks in it that have to be worked out
but the operation that we've had in the
last year has just been tremendous well
we have entire communities in the United
States that are refusing to cooperate
entire state of California refusing to
cooperate with federal officials
endangering the lives of Californians
because individuals in the country
illegally violent criminals are released
they go on and they create and more
havoc for the American people and legal
immigrants I want to close with with
sandy sandy if you could say anything to
you know immigration officials the
government given the fact that you've
lost your sister just a few days ago out
for a beautiful bike ride on a beautiful
day she should be here enjoying her
family tonight she's incredible person
as an American citizen what would you
say let's figure a way out to fix the
system we have we need to fix the system
so that these type of tragedies don't
happen to other families
sandy god bless you thank you for coming
on this show tonight I know it was
really hard and I I know our viewers
really are praying for you and your
family and thank you and thank all of
you
law-enforcement DA's you guys have a lot
of hard work to do across this country
and you guys don't get my
recognition I know you're not even
looking for it but we really appreciate
you so thank you all very very much